-Tonight is the final night
of BTS Week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna miss those...
I really want to take a moment
to just thank the band,
not only for the interviews
and the games,
but every single night,
there's been an incredible,
spectacular,
beautifully directed,
choreographed,
produced performance,
and they're ranking up like
millions of views on YouTube.
They are talented,
talented humans,
and that leads me
to my next shout-out --
their fans, the BTS Army.
They are some of the most
loyal, positive, and fun fans
that you could ever dream of.
And I just want to say thank you
to all of them.
"Chimmy" Fallon loves you.
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
And as a treat for you guys, BTS
is closing out the show tonight
with another
exclusive performance.
And I know
you're gonna love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They are amazing.
-Yeah.
-I don't know how
they just keep doing it.
They're perfectionists.
They just crush it.
Oh, I also want to mention
BTS is performing a special
livestream concert,
BTS Map of the Soul: 1.
It streams worldwide
on October 10th and 11th.
It has all kinds
of incredible technology --
AR, XR, multi-view screens,
and a few more surprises.
Be sure to check it out.
It's gonna be great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really, thank you, BTS.